Ich mag keine Peitschen und Ketten, kannst
du mich nicht niederwerfen, aber du kannst deine Liebe auf mich peitschen,
Baby, peitsche deine auf, ich bin Vanilla-Baby, ich werde
dich würgen, aber ich bin kein Killer, Baby, sie
28 sagt mir, dass ich  Ich bin noch ein Baby, ich bekomme
Liebe in Detroit wie SK Baby und die
Sache mit deinem Jungen
ist, dass das stimmt, das ist
richtig, junger J a c k a ka wie der höfliche
junge Andri, der aka spricht, sie ist ein Alpha,
aber nicht in der Nähe deines Jungen, sie bekommt Qui in die
Nähe deines Jungen, warte mal, Don  Ich weiß nicht, was
du gehört hast, was du über deinen
Jungen denkst, aber sie haben gelogen, dass dein Junge
dumm geworden ist, und es ist ziemlich idiotisch, dass dein
Junge, dass sie ein Jubelaufdruck trägt